[Musica]
[Applauso]
stasera vi parlerò un po delle scintille
che hanno plasmato la finanza
moltissimi non sono a conoscenza della
reale importanza che la finanza nel
mondo e dell'area l'importanza che le
crisi finanziarie hanno avuto nella
storia dell'umanità
la finanza moderna nuovi sostanzialmente
lo dobbiamo ad un accordo sottoscritto
sotto un albero a delle navi che
partivano ma spesso non arrivavano ea
dei bulbi di tulipano il futuro della
finanza invece che potrebbe già essere
presenti e tra noi dobbiamo la crisi
finanziaria del 2008 è un soggetto o la
cui identità è sconosciuta
sostanzialmente la finanza si
caratterizza per una ciclicità ogni tot
di anni ci sono una serie di eventi che
si ripetono ciclicamente molti si
domandano dove è nata la finanza moderna
siamo a manhattan 17 maggio del 1792 24
broker riuniti intorno ad un albero un
platano sottoscrivono l'accordo di
button italiano significa platano e
sostanzialmente danno vita alla prima a
regolamentazione di un mercato
finanziario moderno nasce wall street il
più importante e imponente mercato
finanziario mondiale
la nascita delle azioni però che
sostanzialmente sono ciò che sono
quotati sui mercati finanziari
borsistici
in realtà è molto più antica nel 1600 il
mondo scopre le indie orientali e
moltissime armato armatori iniziano ad
avventurarsi partendo verso le indie
orientali moltissimi partono pochissimi
arrivano il pil motivo è una variabile
impazzita i pirati che sostanzialmente
rendevano impossibile quasi impossibili
ritorno dalle mie orientali di
conseguenza il rischio dei viaggi
iniziato ad essere così economicamente
importante che gli armatori hanno
cercato di trovare qualcuno che potesse
condividere il rischio economico per
affrontare questo tipo di avventure in
questo bari proprio in questo periodo
nascono
quindi le compagnie delle indie
orientali che sono sostanzialmente ciò
che sono alla base di strutture
societarie come le attuali società a
responsabilità limitata società per
azioni proprio l'azione di per sé aperto
il modo di fare imprenditoria agli
investitori dando la possibilità agli
investitori stessi di condividere dei
rischi economici e di andare a ripartire
gli eventuali guadagni
questo modello basato quindi su una
forma di comproprietà collaborazione e
condivisione dei rischi per poter poi
ottenere una revisione dei guadagni è
stato sostanzialmente ciò il modello
utilizzato per varie centinaia di anni
di anni fino a quando poi le società
hanno iniziato ad agire in un modo
sostanzialmente diverso
faccio l'esempio di amazon a maggio è
una società che per esempio per il tipo
vent'anni non ha mai prodotto utili
nonostante avesse a bordo degli
investitori
ovviamente un soggetto investe per poter
avere un ritorno sull'investimento di
conseguenza in presente società che non
erano in grado di produrre utili o se
producevano tutti di non distribuivano
gli investitori hanno avuto iniziare a
spingere moltissimo sulla compravendita
di titoli azionari per cui iniziato
esserci uno scollegamento tra il valore
delle azioni e il valore reale delle
società questo tipo di modello ha
portato a varie crisi sistematiche la
prima delle quali tra le crisi moderna è
stata quella del 1929 di wall street
il cui crollo ha avuto un impatto
devastante su tutta l'economia mondiale
ma sostanzialmente la prima crisi che
l'essere umano ha conosciuto e molto più
antica risale al 1600 è stata
sperimentata dai paesi bassi di paesi
bassi hanno infatti toccato con mano
l'irrazionalità che spesso si produce
nel momento in cui nasce una moda che
poi diventa in qualcosa di non
controllabile riferimento a beni
specifici nel 1600 infatti nei paesi
bassi
sostanzialmente c'è un ottimismo
dilagante i paesi bassi rappresento sono
una superpotenza a livello economico
la compagnia olandese delle indie
orientali domina a livello mondiale c'è
una liquidità
notevole che ha necessità di
concentrarsi su beni sui quali investire
per poter avere un ritorno economico
in questo contesto arriva il cosiddetto
fiore di dio un bulbo i tulipani che non
esisteva nei paesi bassi in realtà
esisteva in in turchia i paesi bassi
iniziano a importare prima c'è un
interesse poi l'interesse diventa moda
poi la moda si trasforma in mani ha di
fatto il bulbo di tulipano inizia ad un
certo punto a scollegarsi totalmente dal
valore di mercato ma il bulbo è stato
alla base di una vera e propria
rivoluzione finanziaria e grazie al boom
di tulipano che nascono i cosiddetti
futures ossia dei contratti futures che
sono derivati che fanno sì che un
soggetto acquisti un bene nel momento in
cui ancora non esiste per ottenerlo poi
in futuro pagando però un importo nel
momento in cui la acquista quindi
andando a speculare sull'eventuale
variazione del valore successivo quindi
cosa succede nei paesi bassi già nel
1600 non solo non si compra compra vende
il tulipano non ci compra vende compra
vende neanche il bulbo addirittura si
compra venne l'aspettativa del bulbo
pagando non il prezzo del bulbo attuale
ma il prezzo del bulbo l'aspettativa del
prezzo del mondo quindi il prezzo il
bulbo il prezzo che il gruppo potrebbe
avere avuto dopo un anno di fatto questo
tipo di cosa ha iniziato a importare
comportare una speculazione estrema e
quindi andare a creare un reale
scollegamento tra il valore finanziario
del bulbo e il valore reale del bulbo si
è arrivati nel 1633 in una cittadina o
nei paesi bassi addirittura a scambiare
un intero palazzo un building per un
solo bulbo denominato il sempre augustus
perché poi in ogni crisi finanziarie
solito interviene intervengono sempre
delle attività di marketing che sono
diciamo molto fantasiose vanno ad
alimentare le aspettative dei soggetti
floricoltori infatti avevano capito che
era possibile lucrare in un modo abnorme
su bubi tulipano e quindi iniziarono a
creare dei nomi fantasiosi associandoli
allarme ad ammiragli uno dei gruppi più
famosi era il semper augustus che di
fatto è stato il bulbo che poi di solito
permetteva di poter acquistare delle
palazzine eccetera nella finanza però
quello che succede sempre come abbiamo
detto è che ci sono degli andamenti
ciclici per cui molto spesso i prezzi
crescono in un modo incontrollabile
dopodichè la crescita diminuisce si
interrompe poi c'è un calo che molto
spesso devastante questo è ciò che è
avvenuto anche il riferimento ai bulbi
tulipano a un certo punto gli
investitori
gli acquirenti intenzionati a spendere
delle fortune per poter acquistare
subito libano sono venuti meno e di
conseguenza il prezzo è crollato e con
un creando un disastro economico per
tutti coloro che avevano sottoscritto
questi più utile perché i soggetti che
hanno sottoscritto i futures avevano
acquistato i bulbi su un aspettativa di
un prezzo molto più alto rispetto a poi
il prezzo reale di rivendita nel momento
in cui il bulbo era era diminuito di
prezzo e questo tipo di crisi è stata la
prima crisi che noi abbiamo conosciuto è
la peculiarità della stessa che per
quanto è stata devastante per gli
investitori dell'epoca ma sicuramente
non ha avuto una portata globale la
crisi del 2008
notissima in realtà è stata la crisi
[Musica]
potenzialmente più devastanti a livello
globale dal 1929 però è stato anche ciò
che ha permesso di ingenerare di creare
una delle più grandi innovazioni
probabilmente in ambito monetario e
finanziario degli ultimi probabilmente
100 anni e c'è una particolare
coincidenza anche a livello tempistico
il 15 ottobre del 2018 il wall street
journal intitolava crisi a wall street
lehman brothers in bilico hajji in cerca
di denaro
praticamente il fallimento di lehman
brother ha creato prima una tesi
finanziare che poi s'è detta
ripercuotere in ambito economico per
capire l'importanza di questa crisi
soltanto negli stati uniti 8 milioni di
persone hanno perso i posti di lavoro
2.5 milioni di aziende ed imprese sono
fallite o quasi fallita e 4 milioni di
immobili sono stati pignorati in meno di
due anni
la cosa incredibile è che però dopo un
paio di settimane da questa crisi
sostanzialmente un soggetto la cui
identità è misteriosa quindi molti
pensano si tratti della cia
molti pensano si tratti di più di una di
un'area una persona ma nessuno realmente
sa di chi si tratta diffonde su internet
un paper intitolato bitcoin è di fatto
va a creare una moneta che
sostanzialmente globale che
sostanzialmente scollegata da un
controllo delle banche centrali
questa è una delle rivoluzioni delle
rivoluzioni più incredibili in attesa
degli ultimi degli ultimi anni per
capire l'importanza di questo tipo di
rivoluzioni faremo anche degli esempi
comunque le concreti nel maggio del 2010
nasce il primo exchange sia nasce la
prima piattaforma si chiamava mount cox
che permetteva di scambiare bitcoin con
del dollari o euro il valore iniziale
del bitcoin era 0.07 dollari nel 2010 un
pizzaiolo probabilmente molto avveduto
decine di accettare al posto di 25
dollari il corrispondevano re corrispon
per due pixel valore corrispondente in
bitcoin nel 2017 quei diecimila bitcoin
corrispondenti a 25 dollari
valgono 198 milioni di dollari quindi
questo fa capire l'importanza della
finanza e delle crisi finanziarie
su tutto ciò che poi avviene la vice
monella nel concreto perché molti
dicevano considera la finanza un mostro
terribile quando ridotta la finanza è
ciò che alimenta molte trasforma in un
gioco cartacea e su ciò che poi in
realtà sono aziende eccetera
comunque anche lì dopo questo questa
esplosione in fase iniziale ciclicamente
anche il bitcoin inizia ad essere messo
in discussione soprattutto perché è
associato attività illegali nel deep web
c'è una piattaforma che si chiama silk
road nel quale praticamente inizialmente
si iniziano a vendere un po delle droghe
leggere e poi a trafficare l'impossibile
questa piattaforma utilizza bitcoin come
valuta di riferimento e di fatto quindi
il bitcoin inizia ad essere associato a
terrorismo traffici illegali eccetera e
cose del genere
i regulators quindi le varie autorità
finanziarie monetari iniziano a
interrogarsi sulla natura del bitcoin
per alcuni e valuta per alcuni è
un'attività finanziaria per altri è da
bandire
totalmente quindi sì ma anche
all'interno di uno del mondo cripto
inizia ad avvitarsi un po questa questa
cripto che molti dipingono un po come la
fine in realtà nascono proprio in questa
fase nuova e cripto valute cripto
attività e cripto asset alternativi e
nasce addirittura un meccanismo di
finanziamento delle società delle start
up tecnologiche denominato ice io che
sostanzialmente è un meccanismo molto
simile alle hype josi alle quotazioni in
borsa titoli azionari molte startup
hanno iniziato ad operare in modo
creativo e quindi sostanzialmente hanno
pensato ok e mettiamo dei cripto asset
vendiamoli e facciamo e andiamo poi alle
star lì su dei mercati borsistici quindi
di fatto loro hanno iniziato a
finanziarsi in questo modo creando dei
veri e propri cripto asset che di fatto
erano simili al sostanzialmente nel
funzionamento alle alle azioni quotate
in borsa e con una sola differenza che
mentre le azioni quotate in borse danno
la possibilità di godere dei diritti
agli utili che però come abbiamo visto
in realtà le aziende ormai non vanno a
distribuire questi cripto asset sono
scollegati quindi sono semplicemente
messi lì stati su alcuni exchange stanno
delle valutazioni di valore il soggetto
che li compra libri acquista può andare
a lucrare nel caso di oscillazioni di
valore tuttavia anche nel mondo pitt
dopo questa incredibile incremento delle
votazioni medie nel 2018 arriva il
cosiddetto quinto winter ossia il ciclo
si ripete la capitalizzazione di tutti
di tutti che tu asse diminuisce in gol
incredibile di 80 per cento addirittura
con una diminuzione che è superiore alla
diminuzione del 78 per cento che si è
avuta nel 2000 in riferimento alla
cosiddetta bolla delle dot.com sia allo
scoppio della bolla legata alle società
tecnologiche e quindi anche in questa
fase c'è la diciamo mazzata finale della
crisi siamo quindi restano 2019 è molto
difficile riuscire a dire quello che
sarà il futuro ma ho voluto
sostanzialmente parlarvi
ciò che sono state delle vere scintille
fava nell'ambito un po del mondo del
mondo finanziario per farvi capire
l'importanza delle crisi molti
consigliano le crisi economiche fino a
finanziare come un qualcosa di
distruttivo come un qualcosa di negativo
nefasto in realtà le crisi economico
finanziarie sono una scintilla e sono
ciò che molto spesso permettono di
mettere in discussione lo status quo
ciò che esiste e di andare a migliorare
e di far evolvere il mondo quindi
l'approccio che noi dobbiamo avere anche
in italia nel momento in cui la
situazione magari economica non è
eccellente e quella di sfidare la crisi
perché la crisi è un qualcosa di
essenziale che ci mette alla prova e che
soprattutto è la base di alcune delle
più grande rivoluzione nella storia
dell'umanità e nella storia della
finanza
grazie
[Musica]